quello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fra i generi che oggi
siamo su gas gas non è una parolaccia
siamo su gaza glory che sarebbe in poche
parole è più il in 3d ma non sto
scherzando veramente ci hanno fatto una
roba tipo è più visite ma è bellissimo
visto un paio di età a terrible tutorial
allora fatevi trovare una roba di ecco
questo ci sono tre personaggi bellissimo
john enjimi earl questo è un gran figo
della madonna e the young family che
ovviamente razzista contro i cinesi però
vabbè tanto non è disponibile quindi non
c'è problema giorni interi a questo
dovrebbe essere liu che il padre di uk
che si chiamano john e jimmy è bello sì
ma come mi fai capire come dio guarda
che ti mi si muove malissimo fermo ma
ciò ed andar dritto zio cioè non è di fi
ma mi spiegate i comandi per l'amor di
dio ma non ho capito ma c'è del sangue
in sto gioco c'è qualcosa di pericoloso
devo solo prendere i check point i può
prendersi un caffè un camino in faccia
questo è pericolo e che cosa sta
succedendo ma sono morti tutti e bava
che cagata
va bene respon perfetto ma mi chiama da
zero veramente prova a rifarlo è strano
sto gioco già non si capisce il senso
prove c'è prima mente il mio obiettivo è
stare in bilico per adesso non migliora
cazzo
e vabbè o sei scemo ai ma posso sempre
gli ostaggi qualche tasto per saltare in
un occhio
cosa vuoi oddio ragazzi durante la gara
la gamba la gamba destra e tutto storto
ok lo ha rimesso a posto non so come va
bene quanto incasinato sto gioco quanto
di qua
finale da dio perfetto proviamo fare
call non son the main se va bene ma
niente cielo bloccato r16 blocca
continuava a fare compal col padre di
ieri sera quindi mi sparano palle di
cannone addosso c'è veramente c'era
lenticchi storia nuova bere che affermi
porca [ __ ] ok
e vabbé bastarde ora abbiamo capito c'è
il sangue fosse anche un po troppo è
anche peggio di sé più is non pensavo
questo d'altro scoperto del cera lenti e
stato fatto un acrobazia incredibile mi
sto cappottando fermo ragazzi cè un
tasto che mette il rallenty se non so se
vi rendete conto delle bici tabaton al
disastro ma quando ti colpiscono i
brutti e tragico ora come hanno stuprato
male la bici e vabbè basta madonna che
schivata non so come non stimati i primi
cannoni perfetto c'è al traguardo è
vabbè ma come lo raggiungo i bidoni mi
proteggono bravi non ci sono neanche
arrivato ragazzi ho già scelto senza
fare il tutorial praticamente uno degli
ultimi livelli e quindi madonna cosa
schivato banco check nord no vabbè
ragazzi mattana [ __ ] nicchia
spider man
sono vivo solo vivo veloce veloce nomi
stanno colpendo ma è velocissimo ho un
piede insanguinato ma solo vivo non
possiamo provare a raggirare i cannoni
in qualche modo tipo così no
non possiamo provarci come faccio
ragazzi devo trovare fermi fermi torno
indietro dies incastrati soli ma sono
minacce nel centro della ciccone ce l'ho
fatta già fatta fermi sono forte brava
quarti traguardi ci sono ma che palle
era un check point quello capito quindi
se adesso vado nell'altro check point
saint i colpi senza che mi colpiscano
ragazzi dovete calibrare un po di più la
difficoltà di sta roba hering
incredibile perfetto ci siamo
questo addio almeno non sono morti
guardiamo il lato positivo
porca [ __ ] calcio
[Applauso]
e io che veramente ho sempre creduto che
fosse uno dei giochi più difficili della
storia è la stronza ok quale è stato mi
porto anche la bandiera su carte è stato
tragico però va bene change trek roof
top pop che come ci sono c'è scritto la
difficoltà del livello no quello di
prima era medium quello di prima era
medium questo hard siamo a posto ragazzi
però ci devo provare più forte di me ma
ci sono i cannoni anche qua non ho
capito truffa oddio no vabbè veramente
ragazzi vedrete i fronti
sta per partire un rallenti epico mi che
hanno volato al figlio e vabbè backflip
tutto qua matt o quasi quasi sul
traguardo a me difficilissimo devono
centrare quindi il tetto e poi ho vinto
non ho capito ma non è che ma che [ __ ]
testo gioco olga mi vuole al figlio di
nuovo
noi invece no stavolta rimasto attaccato
la faccio porca eva marche che c'ero
quasi perfetto perfetto perfetto effetto
questo è quello buono è quello buono
lo dice al rallenty ragazzi sono storto
ancora ancora non è finito nei finito
che succede a mio figlio allora dai
veloci veloci perché non ci posso
credere madama ma come cazzo sono morto
ora non lo prenderò mai più il tetto
nella mia vita ma come cazzo space
va beh va beh sono ma sono già morto
abel l'iva che yes perfetto ragazzi
sparatevi questo sparatevi questo
sparate visto trick madonna cosa fa dove
per ci posso che fa veramente mi è
riuscito
ciao
[Musica]
perché vale il cammino come babbo natale
ho fatto una roba epica farò mai più
nella vita
questo schiantato contro un camino però
è un dettaglio perfetto perfetto bravo
questo volevo era difficile era
difficile
no adesso mi chiami schianta no perché
per un attimo stiamo perdendo il
controllo sarebbe stato divertentissimo
meglio evitare bellissimo livello della
vita mi fate fare anche l'altro hardmac
grinder un livello chiamato tritacarne
mi ispira proprio tanto che bello quindi
io devo devo entrare quaderni mi fate
capire cosa devo fare di preciso non
credo così da arrivare a fini di
supercoppa come faccia passare in
minuscolo ma sei scemo cioè con tutti
gli ostacoli sono morto per caduta ma
veramente un attimo e scusate un attimo
non posso fare così
ah no perché ci sono inter ecco dove che
c'erano i check point in mezzo volevo
provare a ok va le mine niente ragazzi
scherzavo devo farlo normalmente che un
casino se prova a barare al piano
sinistra perfetto bravissimo veloce nati
morale in tv
cioè vabbè ce l'ho fatta solo di non con
la mia sono profilo non ci credo non è
vero dai ma cazzo davvero che aveva
stavo facendo per un attimo ci ho
creduto a un checkpoint quello ora
riesco più lo stesso ci sono proprio gli
stessi ostacoli di è più ministro che
questo non è il traguardo è impossibile
[Applauso]
tutta la [ __ ] me grazie non sai neanche
perdendo tanto sangue e zio va bene con
un altro discorso
full moon madness proviamo a far questo
legami sento fiducioso agli orari yes
keyboards eta controller c'è la luce ma
veramente posso attivare la torcia della
della bicicletta ore geniale fermi
ragazzi io voglio provare andare
perfetto
e questo ciò siamo tolti ok no era
l'altra parte quanto sono storto salve
perfetto non è andata così bene prove
vai vai vai a che cosa è attaccato a
quella che quella palla la demolizione a
rachele megan affanculo
ok questo e fa questo è abbastanza
facile in confronto agli altri ma c'è un
cannone che i coperchi ecco lo stavo
dicendo come che io e cannoni non li
vedo adesso visto però de vico e qualche
a4 guardo veloce se va beh ma siete
scemi sì ma come faccio ad usarla cazzo
di cane
meno male che c'era io non capisco
quando sono check point quando sono
traguardi e batte ok perfetto perfetto
ho fatto ho perso mio figlio ma tanto è
inutile al cazzo quindi va bene sono un
[ __ ] sono ma ben presente cosa vuol
dire un [ __ ] non l'ho visto mai non
po come sono orbo schiva skeet madonna
cosa ho schivato sono volta perché
diciamo schiantato contro il muro ma può
e ci sono delle lame che ti devono
trapassare che a volte sopravvivi non
adesso e muori perché di schianti su un
muro ma sei scemo allora piano piano
piano perfetto però che c'è una lama
liscia devi fare piano piano come mamma
ha fatto perfetto non mi cade la la mano
prefetto un grandissimo tutto contento
sono anche tratto di tutto questo non
avevo attivato o dieci sono le mine
manco finito di dirlo è ok perfetto va e
vice entrati avrà un primo perfetto vai
piano che ci sono le mine piano non far
cadere gli scatoloni che son cazzi poi
tuttosport sono perfetto perfetto come
lo raggiungo me lo spieghi non vedo
dietro porca eva ce l'ho fatta l'ho
presa come stesse ok ok veloce veloce lo
è vietata alla fine non ci posso credere
mai varia velocissimo il traguardo
oddio che è successo ma chi è basta fra
bande ne ho abbastanza ragazzuoli spero
che ebbe più bello di ep lewis per
alcuni aspetti per altri un po meno
prova a [ __ ] 100.000 like per il
prossimo episodio perché il santo iddio
e è in 3d hanno inventato il 3d ragazzi
cioè tecnologia e cosa invece vi è
piaciuto sono un commento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come nidi
adottata descrizione se le si è
rischiata i cibi chiaro che se io vi do
e ragazzi